[Música]
Hola Soy Gabriel callsen y les doy la
bienvenida al Expreso de oriente El
magazim quincenal de France 24 en el que
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
a América Latina Esto es lo que veremos
hoy
se cumplen 20 años desde que Estados
Unidos invadió a Irak y empezó una
guerra larga y devastadora analizaremos
las consecuencias del conflicto con un
especialista de la región
hace 12 años Siria vivía su Revolución
en las calles en contra de barrazat una
convulsión que llevó a una guerra civil
que todavía continúa sin esperanza de
una pronta salida del conflicto
después de siete años de ruptura entre
Irán y Arabia Saudita las dos potencias
de medio oriente anunciaron la
reanudación de sus relaciones
diplomáticas veremos Cuáles son las
posibles consecuencias de este
acercamiento para el mundo árabe
empezamos en Irak donde este mes se
cumplen 20 años desde la invasión de
Estados Unidos al país en 2003 el
presidente George Bush había firmado que
Sadam hussein tenía armas de destrucción
masiva para justificar la invasión algo
que después se demostró como falso la
operación militar llevó a años de causa
en el país y causó la muerte directa de
más de 200.000 Civiles iraquíes para
hablar del tema estamos con Agustín
berrea desde la Ciudad de México Hola
Agustín me gustaría preguntarte Cuáles
son las consecuencias de esta invasión
para la población iraquí hoy
Hola gusto saludarte pues Debemos hablar
de consecuencias directas e
indirectas de 200.000 personas que han
muerto directamente por la acción
militar
Y por supuesto de la caída del régimen
de sedam husein pero en términos de
consecuencias indirectas También tenemos
que pensar en decenas de miles de
personas que quedan lastimadas y que no
pueden trabajar o desarrollar sus
actividades regulares y en un gobierno
que cuando cae quedan un vacío político
y que eso permite que colapse la
infraestructura de salud la
infraestructura de servicios públicos de
luz de agua y esos son impactos que
vamos a seguir viendo en muy largo plazo
a pesar de que son indirectos
Agustín Cómo esta guerra reforzó el
terrorismo fundamentalista en la región
pues una de las cosas que tenemos que
recordar es que el gobierno de Sadam
hussein era una dictadura pero era una
dictadura secular
y en la en política de medio oriente
usualmente tenemos estos dos lados los
secularistas
y lo que se denomina el islam político
cuando cae el gobierno de Sadam que se
que era del partido bat que se
consideraba de Los grandes nacionalistas
de los que promovían este proyecto
político de
de ser en naciones árabes lo que permite
es que hay un pues una oportunidad que
toman justamente muchos movimientos de
islam político que empezaron a pulular
por toda la región Y entonces pasa eso
en en Irak pero también pasan en Siria
que sería también tenía un gobierno
dictatorial pero secular cuando cae el
gobierno Parece que va a caer empiezan a
salir todos estos grupos que ahí
llevaban mucho tiempo
se estima que unos 2500 soldados
estadounidenses siguen en el país para
asistir al ejército iraquí por lo tanto
se puede decir que la guerra se acabó
realmente
podemos decir que la fase digamos de
involucramiento kinético ya terminó Qué
quiere decir eso que digamos las tropas
extranjeras ya no disparan sus armas
dentro de territorio iraquín Pero por
supuesto que están apoyando a una
facción que es la facción del gobierno
irá aquí del gobierno de Bagdad del
gobierno reconocido internacionalmente Y
por qué lo están apoyando porque hay
otras facciones que siguen activas y que
siguen intentando hacerse con el poder
lo que quiero decir es que técnicamente
la guerra acabó en términos de El
involucramiento internacional pero en
términos del conflicto interno sigue muy
activo y no hace falta irse más de una o
dos semanas para ver que los ataques
entre distintas facciones iraquíes
continúan
Muchas gracias Agustín por haber estado
con nosotros
un gusto Saludos
seguimos en Siria hace 12 años los
sirios salieron a las calles para pedir
el fin del régimen de lassad las
manifestaciones fueron violentamente
reprimidas y tomaron un machis
revolucionario unos meses después
soldados de certures de las fuerzas
armadas formaron el ejército sirio libre
La revuelta se convirtió en una guerra
civil 12 años más tarde bachaga sigue en
el poder y una multitud de grupos como
el autodenominado estado islámico han
tomado parte en el conflicto veamos un
repaso de los momentos claves de la
guerra con este informe
al completarse 12 años de la guerra
civil miles de sirios salieron a las
calles de ibliff la única zona urbana
que sigue bajo el control de la
oposición para seguir pidiendo la salida
del presidente bashara lazat y para
conmemorar aquel 15 de marzo de 2011
cuando una masiva manifestación sacudió
Damasco la capital del país
nosotros participamos en el inicio de la
Revolución y estamos aquí hoy con motivo
del aniversario 12 para llevar al mundo
entero el mensaje de que mantenemos las
demandas que motivaron nuestro
movimiento y para dar a conocer al mundo
la opresión que hemos enfrentado
documentación en el marco de la
primavera árabe una ola de protestas
iniciada en túnez y Egipto motivó
grandes cambios en la región controlados
por los gobiernos autoritarios incluidos
Siria desde entonces al menos 613.000
personas han muerto más de 2.1 millones
de personas han resultado heridas y la
mitad de la población del país que antes
de la guerra era de 23 millones ha
quedado desplazada según reporta el
observatorio sirio de Derechos Humanos
el conflicto se ha prolongado con la
intervención internacional y el país ha
quedado dividido principalmente en
cuatro partes el régimen sirio apoyado
por Rusia las fuerzas kurdas movidas por
Estados Unidos la oposición al régimen y
el autodenominado estado islámico y
aunque han intentado mesas de diálogo
para solucionar esta guerra no se ha
logrado ningún acuerdo concreto
en cuanto a los acuerdos políticos que
se ponen sobre la mesa no me comprometo
con un criminal que me dejó
discapacitado mucha gente aquí está de
acuerdo en que no podemos reconciliarnos
con un criminal que nos bombardea
Mientras tanto el conflicto se mantiene
latente el cual parece estar estancado y
lejos de un cambio afectando
principalmente a civiles inocentes
después de haber puesto fin a sus
relaciones en 2016 Irán y Arabia Saudita
finalmente anunciaron en Beijing la
reanudación de sus relaciones
diplomáticas con la reapertura de sus
embajadas y la recuperación de sus
vínculos comerciales recordemos que Irán
y Arabia Saudita mantenían relaciones
tensas desde hace años y habían roto sus
vínculos después de que manifestantes
iraníes atacarán la embajada saudí
enteran Como protesta contra la
ejecución de un clérigochita por parte
del reino Saudita previamente hablamos
con Ignacio rolanski doctor en ciencias
sociales y le preguntamos qué peso
tienen estas dos potencias en medio
oriente Y por qué compiten entre ellas
por qué compiten entre sí Bueno Irán y
Arabia Saudita
compiten por Establecer un liderazgo
hegemónico en el medio oriente desde
hace décadas especialmente de la
revolución islámica de Irán en el 79
buena parte esta rivalidad se expresa
como decía a partir de diferencias
ideológicas y religiosas Irán es un país
musulmán eminentemente Chita mientras
que Arabia sauditas predominantemente
sunita Esta división si bien es
esquemática a los fines de esta breve
exposición ha sido la raíz de muchos de
los desacuerdos y los conflictos que los
vinculan porque cada país Busca promover
su propia influencia religiosa y
política en la región y tenemos que
considerar que en base a estas
diferencias que se articulan con
identidades tribales y étnicas hay
distintos actores que dentro de cada
estado luchan también por ejercer el
poder político entonces
se van vinculando entre sí Irán y Arabia
Saudita con estas luchas intestinas
dentro de por ejemplo Siria yemen entre
otros casos esos son tal vez los más
emblemáticos
también le preguntamos Cómo este
acercamiento afectaría a la región
especialmente a yemen donde Irán apoya a
los Rebeldes suchies mientras que a
rabia saullita respalda al gobierno
yemení pero también al Líbano un país
donde un tercio de la población es Chita
y el otro tercio es sunita
se prevé que este acuerdo
posiblemente afecte distintos procesos
regionales en el caso de la guerra civil
en yemen que se logre potencialmente una
desescalada y una desmilitarización
progresiva del conflicto no hay
garantías sobre esto porque es difícil
de determinar cuál sería realmente la
influencia directa que pueda ejercer
Irán en la agenda de los judíos en tanto
amenaza existencial percibida por Arabia
Saudita es decir los ve como una amenaza
y por tanto por eso es que realiza estos
ataques estratégicos ataques aéreos
podría llegar a darse una especie de
suspensión de hostilidades no es seguro
potencialmente
ambos países Irán el Arabia Saudita
podrían establecer cierto tipo de
cooperación que permite evitar escaladas
esto es todavía decimos en potencial no
no hay garantías de ello en Líbano lo
que se prevé Es que este acuerdo a lo
mejor logre ayudar a
recomponer la integración del Líbano a
nivel regional y facilitar cierto
desenvolvimiento propio de esta cefalía
a nivel presidencial que aqueja al país
a la vez que la queja una grave crisis
económica de manera tal que
un una desescalada de la atención entre
Arabia Saudita e Irán países que ejercen
influencia en distintas fuerzas
libanesas quizás logre ayudar a que la
situación Dentro de este país se
normalice Pero esto tampoco depende
directamente de la influencia o sea de
la política exterior de Arabia Saudita
Irán para con Líbano
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
expresión de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a seguir toda
la información en nuestra página web
Franz 24.com
[Música]